you
[Music]
welcome back to our in Asarco okay I'm
really excited to have Adam frost here
some of you had a chance to meet him
today there will be a reception right
after this awkwardly won't happen in the
hallway because we have no hallway so we
will just make our way out to kind of
the entryway across the hill here
windows and river and food and stuff so
if you haven't had a chance to talk to
him there's time then and I think we may
also be able to have you back tomorrow
for lunch that's possibilities yeah yeah
so you can find him
Adam is a PhD student in Harvard he is
in the history department and the East
Asian languages Department yeah we have
a whole crowd you know it's good you got
information all right
Madame frost is a PhD student Harvard
he's in history and East Asian languages
I believe he came across Jennifer at
some point and she was impressed and
excited and wanted you over here she is
sorry she couldn't be here for dinner in
the talk he is also a Fulbright Student
Award winner
he is currently spending the semester in
Helsinki but we'll have him back in
Boston for next year as he finishes up
also a documentary you made called the
end of bitterness
yeah about everyday lives of beggars in
northwest China I want to see that too
so thanks so much for coming and great
thank you so today I'm going to talk
about my research on the history of
entrepreneurship and underground
capitalism in socialist China and how
I'm using unconventional sources and new
methods to explore the origins of
China's economic rise but first let me
begin with the story so about a two
hours drive north of Shanghai in the
middle of the countryside where it's all
fields and factories there's this 70
story luxury hotel that just kind of
Rises out of the country scape and as
you can see atop this hotel there's a
golden sphere kind of like the Eye of
Sauron and inside of the sphere is a
revolving restaurant which is a staff
exclusively by North Korean waitresses
and here one can dine on fresh sashimi
and french wine and enjoy panner
view of the beautiful surrounding
countryside 10 floors below that there's
a gold theme lounge everything's gold
the walls are gold the floor is gold and
in the middle of that lounge is a one
metric ton
solid gold bull it's worth like sixty
something million dollars and so this
whole thing is it's a cathedral of
conspicuous wealth and it was built to
celebrate the fiftieth year anniversary
of the founding of Hashi the wealthiest
village in China washi is a it's a
strange place it's a mixture of red
theater and opulence everywhere in the
village there are statues of Mao Zedong
standing next to war Ambala
the founder the of the village the
streets in washi are lined by lane after
lane a three-story European villas in
front of every villa there's a BMW
parked in the driveway at the edge of
the village there's this thing called
the world Park which has a replica of
Tiananmen of the Great Wall but also of
the Statue of Liberty Big Ben the arc of
triumph and other things and in this
socialist paradise everything is owned
and controlled by the village
corporation and as long as villagers do
the bidding of the corporation and as
long as they uphold the reputation of
their community then they get to live
lives of socialist luxury but what is
most strange about washi is not the way
it distributes and performs its wealth
but the manner in which it became so
wealthy in the first place
so according to the myth that has taught
to every washi child in school the
villages rise had everything to do with
the indomitable washi spirit and the
singular vision of the the the chief the
the founder wore in ball when the washi
brigade was formed in 1961 it was a
really poor community farmers lived in
mud brick houses and they farmed tiny
parcels of land but under the leadership
of this guy were involved
they banded together and they built
dikes and they dug irrigation networks
and they manually transformed the
landscape and the story goes they
eventually made it amenable to
agriculture and with more productive
lands they began accumulating surplus
which they save and continually
reinvested in the community and after
China's opening up er and reform in 1978
the village voluntarily decided to stay
a collective and it continued to pour
the whole of the community's wealth into
the creation of new collective
enterprises and wash EES model this
collective model of organization later
became known as the soon--and model of
development in China one of the major
ways of growth and development
after visiting washi for the first time
sorry I became really interested in its
history and in the truth of its economic
rise so with the help of some
acquaintances I was able to connect with
a few elderly villagers there and begin
interviewing them and they agreed to
speak with me as long as I kept their
name secret and these individuals began
providing a really alternative and more
compelling explanation for washes rise
according to their accounts during
China's socialist era washi was an
epicenter of illicit economic activity
in the wake of the Great Leap Forward
when there were when the country was
suffering from severe shortages of food
clothing other things the village
established a waste textile station and
they began buying up old clothes from
villagers and the surrounding villages
and recycling it into cloth which they
then sold on gray markets a few years
later the village hired a sent down
worker a guy who had been a factory
worker in Shanghai and who was sent down
to the countryside and they hired him to
help build an ironworks which they used
to began producing simple agricultural
implements by the start of the Cultural
Revolution in the late 1960s why she had
already accumulated enough capital from
these enterprises to purchase an
industrial lathe the punch
press and other really expensive
metalworking tools and such industrial
equipment I was told was actually
readily available they bought it from
the Navy naval officers were selling it
to communities in the area and helping
them actually establish underground
factories and then washi began hiring
more quote-unquote Sunday engineers
these were experts who worked in
state-owned factories and stuff and then
on the weekends they would go and
contract out their labor to informal
enterprises and they began producing
things like really high quality drill
bits and threading dyes and things and
then selling them all over China to
places as far as liao kneeing in the
north and Sichuan in the West so from
these stories I learned that washes rise
really didn't have much to do with this
so-called soon--and model of development
or the washy spirit and while it
certainly took advantage of the market
reforms of the 1980s it's a growth was
not initiated by them rather Hashi
success was a product of the knowledge
and networks and capital that it
accumulated during the socialist era in
other words by the time that China
embarked on the process of reform and
opening-up in 1978 hua she was already
well-positioned to take off and so as I
learned more about this kind of untold
history of washi I began to wonder if
what was true of the village might also
be true of China as a whole were there I
began to ask where there entrepreneurs
who continue to operate and innovate
throughout China's socialist era and if
so what did the processes of
entrepreneurship look like where did
they occur and what effects did they
have on the overall development of the
Chinese economy so these are really
large questions of course but they've
only been tentatively explored in the
existing scholarship most studies have
really focused on the political and
institutional structure of China's
socialist economy they look at how key
institutions such as the commune or the
work unit the dam way
the household rates registration system
how they operated but much less
attention has been focused on how the
economy worked in practice on how people
got things done when the formal system
could and often did fail and this is
mostly due to the simple fact that these
things are really hard to study such
topics demand new sources and new
methods that not all historians are
necessarily comfortable with so three
years ago while I was visiting a Chinese
flea market I came across some documents
related to underground capitalists in
the 1960s there were a dozen or so large
brown folders like this each of which
concerned the case of a so-called
speculator and profiteer told you dhaba
for Chinese people and it was people
like these men who were prosecuted for
engaging in illicit commerce or selling
ration coupons or other economic crimes
each of the cases that I found they
involved summary like this which spoke
of the types of illicit economic
activities that these people were doing
on how much money they were earning on
what type of goods were involved and
these cases dealt with all manner of
things some talked about illegally
produced textiles and illegally hunted
furs some talked about smuggled
wristwatches others talked about musical
instruments and even firearms so all
kinds of things were being traded in
these illicit markets and when I asked
the seller where did you get these
documents he told me that he had bought
them from an archivist in a nearby city
when the archive was doing its cleaning
and that they were part of a much bigger
collection so after chatting with him a
bit more he agreed to take me back to
his house and I ended up purchasing a
whole set of materials this was my first
collection that I bought and he agreed
to introduce me to other merchants who
also had similar stuff so over the next
few years I networked with a whole
community of these document sellers both
in-person and online and I procured tens
of thousands of pages I think about
30-40 thousand right now
pages of materials related to
underground capitalism and socialist
China and what I found is that these
kind of sources as opposed to official
State Archives they paint a radically
different portrait of how the economy
functioned in practice they show that
throughout society there were
innumerable entrepreneurs who are
identifying opportunities to profit from
inefficiencies in the planned economy
and more generally just to make things
work and they offer accounts of for
example farmers who traveled the cities
to sell handicrafts to urban workers or
merchants who purchase large quantities
of goods and smuggled them to other
administrative regions or even
state-owned factories that would procure
goods outside of the system of formal
distribution and buy things at market
prices rather than state fixed prices in
other words the documents you know said
that everywhere there were entrepreneurs
who were filling the voids in the
socialist system so since I'm still in
the middle phases of my research I'm
riding up the dissertation right now
rather than attempt to make a bunch of
big overarching historical arguments I'm
going to show you how I'm engaging with
these sources and how I'm using them to
conduct type both quantitative and
qualitative methods of analysis and I'll
argue that it's exactly through the
process of combining different modes of
analysis that we can maximize the
utility of these sources and that we can
ultimately arrive at deeper
understandings of how the Chinese
economy actually function yeah sorry
yeah yes just the people that got caught
yeah I can talk about that later I'm
writing papers on that but yeah I mean
basically no these are the people that
selectively got caught by the state was
there someone else
yep these are state agencies who are
identifying and prosecuting
entrepreneurs in the economy the
underground capitalist or as they call
it speculators and profit ears yeah yeah
yes yes you got a do a listen economics
the study illicit economics but it's not
just me there's other people that are
doing this as well collecting these
documents and using them to develop new
insights about the maoist economy but
I'm the first one to do it for economic
stuff everyone yeah yeah these are total
no no no these are totally illicit the
state doesn't really care that I'm
buying these because it's just too small
these aren't central government
documents these are local government
documents but basically what happened
was the local government agencies
produce these they conducted all of
these investigations about underground
capitalists in the economy they produced
these investigative reports and others
and there's other kinds of documents
there too and they and they housed them
in local archives but over time just so
much stuff built up the Maoist state was
really good about recording lots of
stuff and the archives filled up so then
they had to have an archival cleansing
to open up space and when that happened
it was during the 1980s and there were
paper shortages in China and so the
state said okay archivist turn your
instead of just burning them turn your
archives over to paper pulpers who will
pulp them and recycle them and would use
them to produce new paper but somewhere
in that chain of custody from archivist
to paper pulp er someone said I bet I
could make a lot more money by selling
these to private collectors and so they
entered into private circulation and
then I was able to track down these
collectors the people who had bought the
documents in the 1980s and then after
you me one he can introduce you to a lot
more and then just working through that
Network I was able to find a lot more of
these documents buy them back and then
basically create my own archive so
that's the gist yep
I've I get that question every time
actually I've spent about seven thousand
dollars which I mean it's a lot for a
graduate student but it's not that much
to build an archive okay so oh nothing I
mean right I mean if these were pulped
it would be you know five bucks ten
bucks you know it's worth noting and
it's waiting in paper but now they're
worth a lot the merchants are selling
them to historians like me and they
realize they can game us against each
other too so they're making nice profits
so as I said I'm gonna use multiple kind
of modes of analysis to engage with
these sources and show how different
modes of analysis allow us kind of
different lenses into how the economy
was functioning in practice so let me
move to my first mode of analysis which
is the kind of most traditional most
established the case study approach the
deep reading of individual sources so
among the thousands of cases of
speculation and profiteering that I've
collected there are a handful of
exceptionally detailed ones which offer
really unique insights into how
entrepreneurs were making economic
decisions and how they were also
justifying their actions to state actors
and to illustrate what this looks like
and how these sources might be used
I'll talk here about the Curious Case of
this man Chong Guang he's a socialist
fashion designer so Chung goo hyung was
an educated man he was born to a small
capitalist family in Hangzhou and after
graduating from middle school he worked
as an accountant for the government and
later as a management of the shop now
after the communist rose to power in
1949 he was persecuted for because he
had ties to the former government and so
he was sentenced to re-educate a
detention and re-education but after he
was released he moved from Hangzhou to
Nanjing and he opened this the hundred
Flowers artisans cooperative and he
began producing clothing patterns such
as these for sale very fashionable pants
as you can see and then he sold these to
socialist consumers and socialist
consumers of course they had to have
ration coupons they bought cloth
they use these patterns to sew and their
own clothing now in 1965 a decade later
Chun came under attack as an unrepentant
capitalist and after a series of lengthy
investigations the so-called market
administration office found Chun guilty
of tax evasion of underground printing
and marketing and collusion with other
capitalists and counter revolutionaries
so according to the investigative
reports Chun was actually the ringleader
of an illicit network of designers who
produced transported and sold
quote-unquote outlandish clothing
patterns such as these very outlandish
as you can see across 23 provinces and
two autonomous governing regions of
China so basically the whole of China
yeah
they're selling it for money I mean
there's money in the malleus economy is
not a cashless economy they out so I'll
say Chun's products were so popular that
not only did you know regular consumers
buy them but even state-run shops began
purchasing them and selling them and
within the span of two years he
supposedly derived more than three
thousand un in illegal profits and this
is an astronomical figure at all I'll
put that into perspective in a little
bit yeah so that's not true for this so
you don't need so I'll actually talk
about the coupon economy very shortly
for these you don't need ration coupons
to purchase them you need receipts and
you're gonna have to have a receipt and
a stub and it's usually one enterprise
buys from another enterprise and there
has to be a whole document trail so it's
complicated but basically the currency
they're using is cash so over the next
ten years chun would be repeatedly
arrested prosecuted and punished for an
array of economic and political crimes
however rather than Raziel than submit
he resisted prosecution the whole time
and he wrote more than a dozen letters
of Appeal to higher government offices
defending his actions and justifying his
motives in these letters he argues that
the real reason he was prosecuted by
this local government agency is that he
had out competed state-run enterprises
he points out a fundamental
contradiction in the government's
position toward individual enterprise
for the Chinese speakers goatee who and
although he although he and another
handful of individuals about a hundred
forty eight thousand people in the
Chinese economy have been granted
licenses to operate independently as
businessmen he argued that if he
actually created products that the
masses desired if he did his job then he
would ultimately run afoul of state-run
enterprises because they believed they
could do everything and such arrogance
he said on the part of these enterprises
had resulted in a general decline in the
quality of goods such as these patterns
as he explained here's a quote from his
case now there are no good clothing
designs why is this in shyamu district
of the RET the red flag blueprint
cooperative struggled to attract
business so they turned to a local
textile company to supply them with
patterns however they soon found that
the patterns the company created did not
suit the demands of the masses the
designs weren't good-looking and the
variety of articles was too limited
as a result sales were sluggish and they
soon suspended production and I love
this last line in this business there is
no shortage of arrogant people who think
they can do everything themselves and
end up failing halfway through so this
is a pretty damning critique right of
the formal socialist economy and the
state-run enterprises and in these
letters of Appeal this is just one of
like I said about a dozen or so chun is
arguing that there are fundamental
limits to the capacity of state-run
enterprises and large-scale collectives
to satisfy society's demands he says no
matter how skilled their employees or
how efficient their factors of
production
there's certain tasks such as the design
of clothing patterns that they're simply
not equipped to handle and he said this
is because they're too far removed from
the people they're ostensively producing
clothing for one more quote last quote
when designing clothing one cannot
create as one pleases nor can one work
while isolated from sources of
information one must unify the social
habits and customs of one's country with
knowledge about the human form and
modern style if one does not proceed in
this way then one will produce bizarre
clothing that is unsuitable for the
masses therefore in addition to
consulting the other country's designs
as well as the intrinsic characteristics
of Chinese I think style I love this
part I also dive into the realities of
life by visiting every clothing shop by
listening with an open heart to the
suggestions of customers by learning
what Styles the masses desire and by
exchanging experience with others in my
trade and it is
these aspects that I accumulate
knowledge and over the passing of months
and years innovate new techniques that
improve the quality of my work so I
think this is pretty amazing this is a
guy writing a letter of protest to state
agencies and he's defending his kind of
entrepreneurial ethic and we see this so
clearly actually in his work so here we
have nine variations on a design for
long-sleeve shirts that are designed for
the laboring masses so we notice that
these shirts are supremely practical I
mean they have high collars and big
pockets and the practicality is further
highlighted by the fact that the models
are shown clutching hoes and their
lunches in this illustration the imagery
is even more overt right the person at
the top right is spooning out slop to
her pigs the person here on the left is
gazing out over her flock of sheep yet
critically these designs are also
fashionable the clothing is much
shapelier than Joan Chan suits there are
also many variations on a single style
and the designs are situated within
scenes of everyday life as we can see
here the young shepherd is standing in a
particularly fashionable pose that not
only acts situates her short sleeve
shirt but also shows how it can be
stylish ly paired with trousers and
loafers and it is these elements of
fashion you know based on intimate
knowledge of consumer desire that
enabled Chun to generate such great
demand for his designs and why
businesses throughout China including
the state-run department stores were
eager to buy his products and then have
them on offer to their customers so
individual cases like like that of mr.
Chun revealed that the individuals who
were prosecuted as so-called speculators
and profit ears in the economy we're
often entrepreneurs who created very
real forms of value in the socialist
economy through the utilization of their
tacit knowledge and the enactment of
different types of value they provide
Joost and marketed goods that consumers
ultimately desired
moreover entrepreneurs like chun not
only subverted state control of
production in exchange but they actively
challenged it by co-opting Maoist
discourse and appealing to the needs of
the masses chun was able to justify he
attempted at least to justify his
actions to the state and legitimize his
contributions to society so we've seen
now how this kind of case study approach
can yeah go ahead
do you observe any kind of behavior
there's one individual so no this is
explicitly not multi sighted as I said
this is the most traditional form of
analysis that's a case study a classic
and of course it's much more detailed
than this but this is my limited
presentation right so that is how most
historians actually would do this kind
of research right they would just focus
they pick five of these cases and that
we do very deep readings of all that I
mean his case is 800 pages long it's
four giant tomes of investigation they
just keep investigating him keep
prosecuting him over 15 years and so
this is like this is the kind of
insights I think that you can derive
about entrepreneurial processes through
the deep reading of materials but now
I'm going to move on to a different type
of analysis much more like the one your
one you're suggesting so we've seen now
how this kind of case study deep reading
approach can yield new insights into
socialist economic practice however this
method as I'm sure you're implying faces
severe limitations when reading a
handful of cases or a single case it's
often impossible to really make sense of
the actions of individuals because you
don't know how they're situated within
broader networks of activity we're still
you can't talk about as generalizability
is this guy the exception or is he one
of hundreds of fashion designers and now
is China we don't know by just reading
his one case and so it's for these
reasons that we need to turn to a second
mode of analysis the kind of mezzo
reading of larger collections of sources
and here I'll show how by reading dozens
and dozens of cases of speculation and
profiteering together we can begin to
identify certain patterns in the modes
of entrepreneurship and to illustrate
that I'm going to focus on one
particular sphere of illicit economic
activity the trading of ration coupons
yep
my next paragraphs so in the 1950s the
Chinese party Communist Party enacted
systems of formal rationing and
distribution at first this began for
products like grain really core products
but then it slowly expanded to other
commodities such as like cotton and coal
and for every one of these core
commodities the government agency would
print and distribute ration coupons so
ration coupons are a little bit
different than what most people think in
maybe the Soviet context so in the
Chinese context they're called priceless
securities which I juncture that that
were theoretically valueless and they
could not legally be bought sold or
traded coupons functioned as
entitlements to make a certain purchase
of a designated amount of good at a
state fixed price so when a consumer
would go to a state-run shop they needed
to come with both coupons and money in
hand without the coupon you can't you're
not entitled to a purchase and without
the money you can't exercise that
entitlement so the coupons and the money
work together in the economy so the
basically the formal circulation of
coupons looks something like this
state agencies at all kinds of levels
would print coupons they would
distribute them to local households or
through people's work groups and the
households would then redeem them at a
number of state agencies or state shops
and things and so this whole system kept
coupons circulating within a really
limited region within a single County
within a single city something like that
and this theoretically tied socialist
consumers to their places of household
registration if you're a farmer who
doesn't have some rations for this city
you're not going to be able to find food
right that's the idea keep people locked
down based upon where they're being
issued coupons however much to the
vexation of the state these coupons
became objects of private exchange and
and entrepreneurs like this guy
would buy up coupons and then circulate
them outside of formal channels so again
here's that formal system and here's how
the most simple form of illicit
circulation would work so you would have
in a simplest type of circulation you
had local coupon traders like that guy I
showed you who would travel from village
to village and they would buy up coupons
from individual households and then
resell them to other households this is
really important some households had
more coupons than they needed other
households were like on the verge of
subsistence if you were a farmer and had
five children or something you or a
factory worker and had five children you
may not have enough coupon to feed
everybody but if you only had one kid
you're probably getting more than you
actually need to support the whole
family
so these merchants helped redistribute
them between households some traders
were also a little bit more
entrepreneurial and they would collude
directly with the state agencies and
they would just buy up whole coupon
books large quantities of coupons and
then research research laid them on a
much larger scale
and there were also more come and then
these activities helped alleviate like I
said the MAL distribution of goods
within communities but there were also
more complex types of circulation that
helped redistribute coupons across space
so when local traders accumulated a
large supply of coupons instead of
selling them directly to households
sometimes they would resell them on to
wholesale brokers and these brokers were
specialists who identified regional
differences in ration coupons and then
they would recirculate them from areas
of lower to higher value their arbitrage
inge prices across time and space and
this involved smuggling the coupons
across these administrative boundaries
which they did through a number of
methods one case I have a ration coupons
I had a big cart full of cabbages and he
had cut all the cabbages in half cored
them out and then stuff them full of
ration coupons and then glued them back
together
and so they use all kinds of methods to
try to elicit ly circulate these across
space in this second type of more
complex circulation the brokers
typically wouldn't sell them on directly
instead they would pass them on to an
intermediary a group of people that are
sometimes referred to as coupon runners
and these are guys who are situated
within the local communities they're
usually young guys with not much capital
but they know everybody so they know who
to sell the coupons to and these coupon
brokers would for example resell some of
them to the bosses of underground
factories that needed to be able to feed
their workers others would sell them to
labor gangs so these guys would hire
whole groups of workers from the
countryside illegally transport them to
the city and then contract out their
labor to formal enterprises so they
needed coupons to be able to feed them
again and other still sold them to black
guest houses and these were basically
underground hotels illicit hotels and
the illicit hotels would maintain stocks
of coupons to sell them to the
businesses and businessmen and merchants
that would travel they're doing
unsanctioned trade and whatever they
couldn't sell in bulk to these kind of
industries they would just recirculate
back directly to households and so
through this kind of system of
circulation you can see we have coupons
being produced here that might be
recirculated all the way into a new
administrative region and to illustrate
briefly how I'm able to restruck or just
read briefly from the self confession of
one man who was a one of those coupon
runners so this guy in his account when
he's explaining to the government
officials that are prosecuting him he
said I began trading these coupons
priceless securities in 1963 at first my
business was small-scale but eventually
I connected with a coupon broker one of
those wholesale agents by the name of
Chien I didn't have any capital at that
time so Chien kicked me the ball ie he
gave me coupons on credit without me
paying him yet and so he gave me 600
year the Capone's I took them and sold
them off to my friends second brother to
water dog some other guys and by buying
coupons at 0.58 UN per gene and
reselling them at point six oh I earned
my first profit of 12 un so we get a lot
of details here about how these networks
are connected how these different actors
are engaged with each other how everyone
is earning money on the spread and it is
through the aggregation of individual
accounts like this that we can begin to
like I said reconstruct these patterns
of entrepreneurial activity and as well
their effects on society and as we've
seen in this brief example just the
illicit coupon trade involved a whole
you know gamut of actors who were
recirculating coupons and who were also
creating an inner subjective basis of
value for things that were supposedly
declared valueless by the state and by
assigning market value to coupons in the
form of black market prices
you know they ostensibly helped transmit
information about supply and demand and
recirculate these coupons into more
productive channels so that's the kind
of meso level analysis I was talking
about the reading of dozens of cases
together but it's still pretty
traditional you're still just looking at
the information contained within sources
and then juxtaposing it together yeah
1960 you have you know a couple million
people in your administrative
bureaucracy and you have a population
that you're managing a 500 million I
mean it's huge it's complex they're
systems of control we're simply not
there they weren't robust enough to deal
with this kind of activity and in fact
they were constantly worried that
they're getting the distribution of
coupons wrong that it's causing some
people to go hungry some people not the
mechanisms of knowledge information
exchange and stuff like that are really
rudimentary so I think there's a
mythology maybe about how like powerful
some of these socialist states are
because they are authoritarian and they
do centralize a lot of control but there
capacity is really limited and so this
is in other words the best they could do
[Music]
and they also try to restrict the space
of these coupons you had coupons at
different levels so I just I gave a very
you know one-dimensional kind of
depiction of this but the coupons are
being printed at the national level the
provincial level the county level and
they're constantly trying to say we need
to produce more county level less
national level because they're being
recirculated illicitly and stuff so the
government's constantly adopting
measures to do these things but then the
entrepreneurs are also innovating new
measures when the government stopped
producing so much national level coupons
they're entrepreneurs responded by
illegally like counterfeiting them so
they have a fine if you're not gonna
produce them we'll produce them and so
they actually smuggled national level
coupons out to Hong Kong where they had
really sophisticated printing presses
and printing operations and where the
government couldn't crack down on them
and so Hong Kong would just produce tons
of these counterfeited things and then
recirculate them back into the back into
the economy yeah
but practically no they just simply like
I said they don't really even know how
much is being produced right and for
example you might know how much is
formally being produced but all of these
people are producing stuff on the side
and you don't even know how many coupons
are being printed really because it's
all these different state agencies or
each printing them sometimes they're
overlapping sometimes some areas have
over printed and other areas haven't so
there's all kinds of inefficiencies
associated with this formal system which
have to do with state capacity and also
with problems of knowledge and so the
entrepreneurs these people these elicit
coupon brokers are responding to those
inefficiencies and they're trying to
profit from them and and in general I
think they're making things work a
little bit better yep but it depends on
who the government is right so the
central government may think that but
the local government may say hey we need
underground factories we need stuff to
be produced here you know the
state-owned enterprises aren't being
supplied with enough materials where are
they going to get them if they can't buy
them from underground factories so yeah
what you see is the emergence of this
complex ecosystem of illicit circulation
which supports a whole other you know
kind of illicit industries like I said I
just mentioned underground factories
black gas houses and the labor contract
teams these are all kind of illicit
endeavors - and they're all so there's a
complex economy that's being built out
of these actions yeah
the question is so I mean why are the
illicit folks able to just constantly
only they know I mean like I said it's a
negotiated process right like it's goin
back and forth all the time there's
crackdowns and then loosening jobs and
so on and so forth this is always in
flux I would say that they're the
illicit people are closer to the ground
they use their personal networks to
accumulate knowledge you'll ask your
uncle who lives in the city next door
hey how much are the coupon prices over
there
when he comes to visit and then you
transmit that knowledge maybe to your
network I found out that people were
using Telegraph's and letter networks
and things like that through the former
postal system and encoding kind of
messages about how much the coupons cost
there so they were using all manner of
like underground channels to transmit
this information and in fact like their
information a lot of times was a lot
more it was a lot deeper because the
state wasn't even collecting this
information so they have much better
knowledge about supply and demand in
many ways than the state does yeah so
let me move on so I'm gonna move to the
third type of analysis so we saw the
micro case study and there's kind of
like mezzo level network e type of
analysis and finally I want to say
there's a role for macro level analysis
to so while mezzo love analysis enables
us to observe observe assemblages of
people and goods in society and in the
economy rather than individual actors it
still offers little insight into the
macro structure of economic practice and
it doesn't really tell us anything about
the scale and scope of informal economic
activity and to get a sense of these
things we have to zoom out further still
and adopt a really bird's-eye view of
these sources and the way to do this I
argue is by analyzing them as sets of
quantitative data so last year I
procured a really large collection of
over 2000 cases individual cases
of speculators and profiteers from a
single County in China it's this place
right here at China and it's now part of
Hangzhou a Lake County in the middle of
Georgia and over the course of eight
months I read through these two thousand
individual cases and I typed up types of
data that were contained within these
documents these are all handwritten
manuscripts so the only thing I can do
is paint it like OCR for Chinese text is
not as developed as you know phonetic
Western script and manuscripts are just
impossible you're not gonna be able to
anything so I just had to manually type
up everything but I was able to build a
large relational data set don't worry
about the specific information there but
the idea is that every case was entered
as a unique row in this data said
they're all assigned a unique number and
then they're related so we have the
sheet shows all the individual cases
this sheet shows all the goods so for
example one case might involve five
different types of goods so we use these
IDs you know one two many kind of thing
we also have a lot of information about
the people that were involved who are
being prosecuted and then I also have
information on the edges the the
connections between places if someone
buys some good in Hangzhou and moves it
to Shanghai I can establish an edge
between those places and so we get a lot
of information about like I said the
people involved in illicit economic
activities the goods that are being
seized by the state agents and how these
entrepreneurs are ultimately punished
and so what do these tell us about the
functioning of the macroeconomy
well first the data set reveals
something about the scale of illicit
economic activity here we can see a
distribution of cases these are the
value of cases calculated by state
agents ie the amount of money and goods
that they seized at the prices they
evaluate them at which are much much
lower than market prices as we can see
the data has a huge right tail and it
actually extends into the tens and tens
of thousands but the mean value we get
is about two hundred and twelve RMB so
the mean case involves about two hundred
and twelve
army of goods in their calculation now
because these goods are being calculated
at the prices officials are using rather
than the market values this is really
strong lead outwardly biased and when
they're seizing stuff like ration
coupons well those are theoretically
valueless so they just enter zero for
that so these cases actually involve a
lot more money than this it's
approximately at least twice as much but
anyway we'll use that 200 RB value to
just get a sense of how big it is so to
put this in perspective we can compare
this this is Angus Madison and he's he
he looked at the per capita consumption
figures throughout the socialist era and
as we can see
rural consumption this red line grew
really slowly throughout the entire
period and in fact it never really
exceeds a hundred and fifty RMB until
almost the reform era this means that
the mean case which involved the seizure
of more than 200 rmb of goods
represented nearly two years of
consumption for a rural worker so these
are a lot of goods being seized in other
words the illicit economic activity at
least the ones that was being prosecuted
by the state had scale the mean
entrepreneur that's being prosecuted is
not a farmer selling a couple of
chickens it's a trader who's you know
dealing in a quantity of goods that
represents years of income for the
average worker more interestingly though
the data set also provides insight into
the spatial scope of these activities so
here we get the spatial distribution of
these networks don't worry about the
value but just get the general kind of
impression of the of the shape of the
networks so as we can see illicit
activities did not just occur within
administrative units remember 20 on is
this green one right here the illicit
activities are not bound up to that
immediate region rather they're being
carried out across really large spaces
as we can see in this magnified area
this kind of core cluster for the people
that know the geography of China this
core cluster kind of transitions
smoothly into adjacent provinces as well
it's not being contained by
administrative boundaries the the these
activities are transgressing boundaries
and we also saw there's distal
connections which extend all the way to
the very north of China and it well into
the interior and what I find really
interesting if we compare this map with
this one this is from William Skinner
some of you may know him he was a kind
of anthropologist geographer kind of guy
and he had this classical delineation of
the regions the macro regions
physiographic emaki regions of China and
he said these are the regions in which
traditional commerce networks existed so
if we compare our core region here to
this it looks a lot like Williams
Skinner's lower Jung's of macro region
and from this kind of preliminary
evidence we might conclude two things
one the economy was will a a lot more
networked than previous people have said
there's a lot more network connections
between places and to elicit economic
activity it looks like is being shaped a
lot more by these traditional networks
than by the socialist administrative
boundaries oh he's talking about
Imperial China for like five hundred
years so according to skinnier this is
this is how commerce was carried out in
Imperial Chinese society so I think
these are some of the insights that we
can develop through quantitative
analysis of these sources so to briefly
summarize in this talk I've highlighted
the lacuna in our understanding of the
Chinese socialist economy and I tried to
point to the use of these unconventional
sources bought from secondary document
markets as a possible means of beginning
to fill this void moreover I've argued
in favor of a mixed method kind of
bottom-up approach to analysis which
really differs from how historians have
tried to explore the economy in the past
as I've shown while the traditional case
study method that other historians would
use enables us to explore some really
interesting aspects of entrepreneurship
in society such as the
is evaluation and the legitimization of
their activity it also suffers from
really strong limitations in order to
make more generalizable claims and deal
with issues of scale and scope we must
read increasingly large collections of
these grassroots sources at different
levels of distance and I've just
suggested that you know no no single
mode of analysis how I've generically
turned the macro mezzo micro none are
intrinsically superior to the others but
each lens two different types of
questions and each yields insights which
really can be combined together and use
to maximize the utility of these sources
finally while I did not explicitly
attempt to make really big overarching
historical claims the implications I
think of this research are far
wide-reaching as we've seen from these
limited vignettes the socialist economy
was quite dynamic and complex at least
way more so than previous scholars have
suggested and it requires no great feat
of imagination to see the connections
between these entrepreneurial processes
these nascent kind of things that were
building up during the socialist era and
the broader processes of historical
change how the Chinese economy takes off
in the 1980s a and I'll be very happy to
talk about this and anything else you
want to talk about in the QA thank you
[Applause]
yeah
and then off the area molded from
doubles analysis is like a notion of
baseline I'm ready to start by the
homonymous scale you know I know that
there are macro analysis I know that
this case the fashion design with micro
analysis yeah I still don't know whether
this is I'm wondering this example
yeah so the one I think you know a we
face a fundamental problem as we do with
any kind of like Mao acero sources for
one the high-level statistics that some
people use are just garbage I mean
they're they're pretty much made up and
there's a really big knowledge problem
in society right if you turn to those
high-level statistics they are so
subject to various kind of political
incentives and mis incentives that you
really can't trust the data so I think
the only thing we can do is do this kind
of reconstruction of like bottom up like
this bottom-up method of analysis of
using large collections of sources to
rebuild data and as you say I mean this
suffers from limitations to because
ultimately the people that we know about
are the people who were prosecuted by
the state in some sense they're the
people who failed at entrepreneurship
right I mean the really successful ones
never got caught and I've interviewed a
lot of those people actually and they
went on later to form really impressive
enterprises in the 1980s and actually
China's first big generation of
entrepreneurs after reform and
opening-up it was mostly these guys who
were doing underground illicit economic
activity in the 60s and 70s so anyway
there's fundamental limitations to how
we can extrapolate this but there are
some things we can do this at least
provides a baseline we can say we know
at a minimum this is how big the economy
is and then of course then we can try to
do clever tricks to extrapolate from
that like does this represent 10 percent
of economic activity we can look at for
example as you have waves of political
prosecution as you have like these kind
of mass campaigns right where the
government will say you need to
intensify your crackdown on capitalism
we can look at how as the cases of these
anti these attacking speculators and
profiteers increase
the value of the activities decrease so
you can maybe see then like how they're
getting into more increasingly marginal
kind of entrepreneurs and stuff like
that so we can play with that to get a
sense the next big thing I'm doing it's
like I said that database took 8 months
to construct and there's all other kinds
of analysis we can do from that but in
order to make it really useful I need to
compare it to another region so I have
another county in China right now where
I have over a thousand cases and so we
can do similar we have similar
longitudinal data where we can begin to
compare and contrast for example how
economic governance in one County versus
another County how for example how much
did local government officials protect
entrepreneurs versus how much did they
you know prosecute them like to death we
can begin to do ask questions like this
and then also through those types of
analysis also get a little bit better
sense of the scale of activity and then
finally as you said then we can start
comparing it to formal industries and
stuff directly and then but you have to
make a lot of extrapolations from this
so I think the best thing to do first is
establish the baseline to say look at a
minimum this is how big a listed
economic activity was and we know it's a
lot bigger and then but then it's just a
matter of you know okay what what you
know what ratios are we applying like
what kind of you know
since we know how big those are later
yeah yeah I think I think another thing
to think about when you're thinking
about entrepreneurship in this area so I
do care about the quantitative aspects
but there are really interesting
quantitative aspects which are
fundamental right so the fact that these
individuals are building networks the
fact that they're a massing
entrepreneurial experience and the fact
that they're accumulating some capital
prior to reform and opening-up is really
critical because it's this knowledge for
example it's the knowledge of how how do
you navigate this margin of
acceptability all of these people are
doing illicit stuff but it's only the
ones who are really egregiously
violating the law that are being
punished and of those even most of them
actually most of these guys they're not
like being sent to labor camp they're
not being executed actually the state
this is this is fascinating and I didn't
include this analysis but I'm working on
it right now the state is just fining
them and in fact a lot of times it
doesn't even find them it just ceases
their Goods and sometimes when it ceases
their goods they don't even just seize
them they pay them for them they just
pay a discounted price and that speaks
volumes to me right the fact that you
have this state are resting these
capitalists who are supposed to be the
worst people in society the the deepest
threat to socialism the fact that you're
arresting them taking their goods and
then paying them for them and so I
really so yeah so I think you see what
increasingly over time local government
officials start becoming really they
recognize the value of these people and
they start working with them and they
say okay even if we are gonna arrest you
just take this fine and then keep doing
what you're doing that kind of thing
so there's a lot of tacit negotiation
going on anyway I think all of these
kind of quantitative findings to our
qualitative findings are really
important for understanding where
China's Chinese entrepreneurship comes
from where are the origins of like the
economic success later comes from yeah
sorry
yeah so the first thing I was thinking -
it looks like the drug trade it looks
like someone you know running like
heroin or something like that like that
kind of organizational structure is
pretty similar so okay one I would say I
need to clear up something so I'm not
when I'm talking about entrepreneurship
I'm not talking about just petty
entrepreneurship I'm not talking about
entrepreneurship at the margins and
things like that these entrepreneurial
functions are being engaged people are
doing this underground economic activity
are both state actors non-state actors
they're informal enterprises they're an
underground enterprises so it's
something that really permeates society
and as you were asking the networks the
networks include the groups of these
people so for example I interviewed some
guys that used to work for state
agencies and every state agency has to
have a procurement officer he's the guy
that gets you your goods that your state
agency needs every factory has one - and
everything and I found out that in one
city in China there were more than
30,000 of these procurement officers
illegally they're buying up wood because
wood is like a really rare you know
thing and it's a short supply in the
Maoist economy and I was asking the guy
and it's really far away I mean it's
like you know the distance from say
Miami to Boston like that's how far away
the the where the guy was based his
affiliated institution and then the wood
the place he's buying to would ask him
how did you get it back what were you
doing he said well first you have to go
there and then you have to take the
officials out to dinner and you have to
give them cigarettes you have to do you
know you have to smooth them a little
bit and bribe them a little bit and then
there will write you a coupon saying
okay you get this much wood but of
course it's still illegal like it's
still not part of the formal procurement
system so then when that wood is loaded
on the train you can't let it get
inspected by the train officials so then
the people have to run ahead of the
train the trains are slow at that time
not that
or you run ahead of the train and in
every inspection station you then take
out all the inspection officers to
dinner
give them some cigarettes and then by
doing that you get your goods back home
all the way and and this involves you
know like all manner of actors you have
state actors or the main ones who are
doing it you have like inspection
officials you have underground
entrepreneurs that are helping them like
move the wood and do other kinds of
stuff too so you have like these
networks that are yeah really big and
they're involving all manner of kind of
formal and informal actors yeah sorry
how did this compare with the fixers in
the Soviet economy which I gather
informally we're also extremely
important yeah yeah I mean III see it as
being very similar there are maybe some
critical differences exactly I think so
my argument would be the reason why the
Chinese do so much better is because
they don't immediately try to transition
to capitalism and instead they kind of
institutionalized this so they basically
say okay there was a so over the 1970s
leading up to reform and opening-up I
have my quantitative evidence now that
shows that these prosecution of illicit
economic tivity ramps up but people keep
failing like the government is trying to
suppress this underground capitalist
stuff and it just it's not working
there's more and more there's reports by
government agencies saying the number
we've led five major crackdowns and the
number of illicit merchants in the city
just keeps growing and and so like and
and then eventually you start to have
this tide of local government officials
I was actually able to interview I think
he's the first man in China first local
government official who opened up this
thing who finally said the cracking down
is not working I'm just gonna let them
do it
and that was in late 1976 1977 right
before reform and opening-up and so in
my opinion reform and opening-up when
dung Xiao ping said you know we're gonna
reform the economy he was looking to
there was all kinds of report
that were being sent up about the
pervasiveness of illicit economic
activity he was looking to that and
saying look it already exists so now
it's just a matter of either formalizing
it or keep failing and suppressing it
and so he was able to at least at a
minimum harness that momentum that was
building up and then use it to push for
reforms and then of course once the
reforms start everything explodes it
just happened so much faster than they
had had intended to but in the 1980s I
think you see the government kind of
recognized the importance of this space
for negotiation to allow people to break
a little bit of the rules and then
whatever works will formalize failure of
the Soviet Union economy in the latter
half of the eighties and one of the one
of these things was the comparison with
the Chinese and his theory is it was
because of the Cultural Revolution that
the Chinese did so well because the
Cultural Revolution sort of correspond
to Stalin's terror but it was much more
recent so it'd been much less
opportunity for institutional structures
to build up that would effectively
resist liberation so I would agree with
that impart I would say and I long a
showing at MIT and I our co-authoring a
paper on this our argument is yeah the
Cultural Revolution mattered a lot it
actually but it had the opposite effect
of what they intended so the yeah yeah
so the Cultural Revolution it was you
know they intended to crack down on the
capitalists but what ultimately happened
was the whole bureaucratic apparatus
came under attack and stuff effectively
shut down so the the Gong Chung to the
Bureau of Industry and Commerce
basically stops functioning during the
Cultural Revolution and these were the
main guys charged with you know
governing the economy and they actually
create this new institution beautiful
name
office of attacking speculators and
profit ears but it's a political
institution and the way it's trying to
attack these underground capitalists is
very different it's not doing it
systematically it's picking a couple of
people and then parading them you know
in front of society to put them on show
and so our argument is yeah actually the
Cultural Revolution by shutting down the
bureaucratic apparatus it effectively
created space in especially the rural
economy for these entrepreneurs to
really start doing new stuff and and and
that led to all kinds of the formation
of these networks formation of
underground factories and lots of
innovation sorry we have to I'm sorry to
say but we have a reception we have some
food and snacks just outside the hall if
you just passed through the elevators on
the other side I would highly encourage
you all the choice for a few minutes and
around so
[Applause]